Herkese selamlar sevgili 9. sınıflar
nasılsınız bakalım? Umarım keyifler
yerinde her şey yolunda gidiyordur. 3ün
temaya geldik. Üçgenler diyeceğiz. İki
dersimiz olacak bu tema içerisinde. Önce
üçgende açılar diyeceğiz. 16. dersimiz
devam ediyoruz. 17. derse de açık kenara
geçiyoruz. Tabii ki de nereden devam
ediyoruz? Mor sunucuğumuzda kaldığımız
yerden devam ediyoruz. Yeni Maarif
modele uygun dop dolu bir kitaptır. Önce
ne yapıyoruz? Seninle beraber burada bir
özel ders formatı birlikte dersimizi
halledeceğiz. Tamam mı? Üçgende açılarla
ilgili yine çok güzel sorularımız var.
İspatlarımız var. Yeni Maarif modele
uygun şekilde ilerleyeceğim. Sonra sana
buradan ödevlerini vereceğim. O ödevleri
de kare kodlarla biliyorsun
ulaşabiliyorsunuz. Dolayısıyla da dolu
dolu yani 9. sınıfı 9. sınıfta bitirme
mottosuyla ilerleyeceğiz. Ama bir diğer
duyurum daha var. Şimdi yarı yıl tatili
geliyor. Özellikle de matematik temelimi
artık oturtmak, sağlamlaştırmak
istiyorum diyenler için bakın tam yarı
yıl tatili için özel. 14 günde sıfırdan
matematik kampı. Bu nedir? 14 gündeki
sıfırdan matematik. Yani benim matematik
temelim sağlantılı. Temel işlemlerde
zorlanıyorum ya da yavaşım diyen gençler
sizlere sesleniyorum. Kesinlikle 10
numara 5 yıldız bir kitap ve kamptır. Bu
14 günün biz 13 gününü zaten bitirdik.
Son bir günü kaldı. Onu da zaten ara ara
yayınladığım videolarda fark edeceksin.
Göreceksin. Matcore'u bitireceğiz. Sen
de ne yapıyorsun? Yarı yıl tatilinde
açıyorsun. 1ci dersten itibaren bunu bak
daha güncel 1 ay önce çektik tüm
videolarını. Eee, güncel bir şekilde
sıfırdan matematiğini halledeceğiz. Bu
sıfır sadece bizim giriş seviyemiz
olacak. Ama bu kitabı bitirdiğinde yarı
yıl 14 günde hemen bunu atacak
yapacaksın, atacaksın. Bu kadar net bir
şekilde çalışmamızı yapacağız ve bu 14
günde matematiğimizi iyileştireceğiz.
İkinci döneme ve tabii ki de sonrasına.
Yani sadece 9. sınıfı değerlendirme,
düşünme artık önümüz biliyorsun 10.
sınıf. Ondan sonra bölüm, sayısal, sözel
hangisi olacağın belli değil. O yüzden
daha belirlemek için bu kitap sana
yardımcı olacaktır. Burada hem konu
anlatıyoruz sonra bol etkinliklerimiz
var. Bin soru var. O kadar söyleyeyim.
Etkinlik, alıştırma, örnek, çoktan
seçmeli sorular. Hatta çıkmış sorular.
Bak biliyorsun Milli Eğitim Bakanı
ufaktan çıtlattı. Sistem değişmeyecek
siz hayırdır nereden çıktı böyle
düşünceler diye söylemeye başladı. Demek
ki sistemde çok fazla oynama olmayacak.
Dolayısıyla da ne diyoruz? Sıfırdan bu
matematiği halledim. Bu kitap her sınav
türü için aslında geçerli. Yani temel
matematik var. Hiç görmeyenler için
şöyle bir içindekiler kısmını göstermek
istiyorum. Hani neylerle nelerle
karşılaşacağınızı da şöyle görün. Burada
14 dersimiz 14 başlığımızı şu şekilde
görü bak tam sayılarla başlayacağız.
Bayağı temelden Ebopek oku var.
Çarpanlara ayırması var. Üstü köklüsü
var. Bu sene zaten gördün. Bunun daha
temeline, derinine iniyoruz. Dolayısıyla
yarı yıl tatilini boş geçirme. Hiçbir
şey yapmasak matematikte şöyle
temelimizi sağlamlaştıralım dedim ve
seni ders ekranıma aldım. Haydi biz
9'dan devam. Şimdi üçgende açılar
diyeceğiz öncelikle. Tabii ki de üçgenin
iç açılarının ölçüleri toplamına bir
bakalım. Yani az buçuk belki de bildiğin
mevzular ama ben yine de hiç
bilmiyormuşsun gibi anlatacağım. Şimdi
bak öncelikle ilk bilgimiz yeni müfredat
dahilindeki ilk bilgimiz nedir? İç
açıların ölçüleri toplamı 180°. Üçgenin
iç açıları toplamını biliyoruz. 180 üç
açının toplamı. Şimdi tabii nedir? Bunu
ispatlamamız gerekiyor. Bunun ispatı
için iki yöntemimiz var. Birincisi şu
hani eee tabii ikinciyi tercih ederim
ben bu arada ama birinciyi de söylemiş
olalım. ABC üçgeninin gençler
köşelerindeki parçaları kesip aralarında
boşluk kalmayacak şekilde yan yana
doğrusal bir düzleme yerleştirdiğinde
yani ne yapıyoruz? Bak şuradan
kesiyoruz. Buradan kesiyoruz. Buradan
kesiyoruz. Bu üç parçayı eğer yan yana
yerleştirirsek bir doğrusal düzlemde
oturuyor. E bir doğrusal düzleme
oturuyorsan sen, e ben burada o zaman
doğrusallıktan dolayı sizin üçünüzün
toplamı 180° derim. Çünkü ben doğru
açının 180° olduğunu biliyorum. Üçgenin
iç açılarını bilmiyorum. Dolayısıyla ben
sizin ü tane açınızı kestim.
Yerleştirdim düzleme. E siz tam oldunuz
oğlum. Tam oturdunuz. O zaman buradan
doğrusallıktan yola çıkarak diyorum ki
sizin üçünüzün toplamı 180. Peki daha
aslında teknik detaylı ispatı şudur.
Şimdi ABC üçgeninin A noktasından geçen
ve BC kenarına paralel olan kırmızı bir
çizgi çizeceğiz. Şimdi üçgenin iç
açılarını hocam dedi ki ispatla. Bak
şimdi ne yapıyorsun diyor? Üçgeni
çiziyorsun işte açılarını ver. A B C.
Sonra diyorsun ki la oğlum buna bir
paralelde ben çekeyim. Benim neyim
eksik? Ben de çizgi çekebiliyorum deyip
çat diye üstten alttaki kenara paralel
bir ne yapıyorsun? Doğru çiziyorsun.
Bunu neden yapıyoruz? Çünkü biz şunu
biliyoruz. Oluşan şekil ile beraber
bizim karşımıza iç ters açılar çıkacak
ve oraya yazıyorsun. İç ters açılar eşit
olduğu için biz bunları iç terslere
taşıyabiliriz.
Şimdi iç terse bakalım.
Şimdi mesela B açısı e o burada Z yok
mu? İşte Z kuralı hani o zaten nereden
geliyor? İki paralelliğin arasında
olmalarından dolayı geliyor. Bu buraya
bakıyor, bu buraya bakıyor. E bunlar hem
içeride hem de tersler. O zaman eşittir
demiştik değil mi? Birazcık 7. sınıf. Ha
şimdi bu o zaman B açısını buraya
taşıyabildik. Bu C'yi de şuradaki ters
Z'den dolayı zor biliyorsun bunları
zoronun şeyi C'yi de taşıyabildik. O
zaman ne oldu? Yukarıda doğru olarak
çizdiğim arkadaşı üç parçaya ayırdım. Üç
açıya. Bunlar da A BC. E o zaman AC
toplamı 180° olduğunu şak diye
ispatlamış olduk. Tamam. Mevzu bu kadar.
İspatını da yaptım. O zaman adcuk soru
çözelim diyor. Seni şöyle 1inci soruya
alıyorum. Şöyle çıtırdak bir şekilde
başlayalım. Bilinmeyen açıları
bulacağız. Şimdi 3üncü açı. E ben
biliyorum ki üçünün toplamı 180. Bende
var 150. Bende var. Bende var. 150'yi
çıkarınca 3üncüye ne düşer? 30 düştü. 1.
soru knockout. İkinciye baktım. Burada
çaktırmadan sana 90'ı verdik aslında
değil mi? Dik açı 90. O zaman elimdeki
malzemeler 90 ve 63. Ben bunları
doplaştırırsam 153. 180'di. İç açıların
ölçüleri toplamı. 153'ü çıkarırsam
burada 7, burada 2. Yani y açısını ne
buldum? 27 buldum. Hop 3üncüye geçtim.
İki açımız 70 ve 52. Toplaşırsalar 122.
180'den 122'yi çıkarırsam ne olacak? 30
desek 50. 58. Dolayısıyla 3üncüye ne
düştü? 58 düştü. İşlem hatası yaptıysam
senden bilirim. Gideceksin yoruma
yazacaksın. Hocam yanlış çıkarttın diye.
Doğrusunu öğreneceğiz. Şimdi bunlar hani
basit şeyler. Topla çıkar mevzuları.
Biraz daha biz çetrefilli mevzulara bir
giriş yapalım gençler. AC üçgenmiş.
vermiş sana bunu. Bir de demiş ki 140
dereceyi veriyorum. Tamam. Bir de bilgi
var. 3 tane ıdıvıdı iki tane ıdıvıdıya
eşitmiş. O zaman diyor ikinci ıdıvıdı
yani EBF açısının kaç derece olduğunu
bul. Şimdi ne yapacağız? Birincisi ben
140'ı biliyorsam e buranın zaten doğru
doğru diye 2 saattir konuşuyoruz değil
mi? Doğruysa 180° arkasında ne kalır?
40°erece kalır diyebilirim. 180'den
140'ı çıkarttım 40 kaldı. Tamam. Şimdi
sen bana ne diyorsun? E AC diyorsun.
Şimdi bak birini 3 ile çarpacağım.
Birini 2 ile çarpacağım ve eşit
çıkmaları lazım.
Pardon. O zaman 3 ile çarpacağım
arkadaşa 2k derim. 2 ile çarpacağıma da
3k derim. Böylece bak 3 x 2 6 2 x 3 6
eşitliğimi sağlatmış olurum. Şimdi bu 2k
3k'ları gidip yerine yazayım. Birincisi
EAC. Neredesin sen? EAC. E AC. He
şurasıymış. O zaman ben sana ne dedim?
2K demiş oldum. Hadi bakalım. Yeni ismin
hayırlısı uğurdusu olsun. Bir de ne var?
EBF. EBF. Neredesin? Seni de bir
görelim. Şöyle. EBF. H şurası dışarıdaki
açı. Sert soru. Şuraya da 3K'yı
yapıştırdım. Şimdi ben yine 180'e
tamamlayabilirim. Yani şu arkasının 180
- 3k olduğunu söyleyebilirim. Neticede
180 açının bir tarafını 3K biliyorsun.
Arkayı nasıl buluyorduk? 180'den
çıkartarak. Aynı şurada yaptık ya.
140'tı ya hani 180'den 140'ı çıkarttım
arkasını buldum. Burada da 180'den 3K'yı
çıkartacağım arkasını bulacağım. Mevzu
bu kadar. E hocam şimdi ne yapacağız? E
iç açıları toplamı 180°. Artık eşitle
geç yapıştır. 1inci açın 180 - 3k
+ 2k şunu yazdım ve + 40°. Bunu neye
eşitleyecektik? E üçünün toplamı 180'e.
Şimdi bu denklemi çözelim. 180'leri
pazara gönderdin. Buradan ne geldi sana?
-1k geldi. At bunu karşıya. + k olsun.
Burada da sadece solda 40 kaldı. O zaman
K'yı ne bulmuş oğlum? 40. Dur. Neyi
soruyordu? EBF. EBF. Neredesin? Heh.
Şuradasın. EBF. E ben sana 3K demişim.
Dolayısıyla K'yı da 40 bulduysam 3 kere
40'tan sen 120'sin. 120 derece buldum.
Geçtim. Bu sorudan da geldim 3. soruya.
Şimdi A B C 1 Bu arada şunu söyleyeyim.
Bu soruyu hani hocam iç açıların eee iki
iç açının toplamı bir dış açıya eşit mi?
Oradan da çözeriz ama daha onu
anlatmadım. Birazdan anlatacağım. Azıcık
sabır ya. Şimdi 3. soru. Kaç aylıksınız
siz? Azıcık bekleyin. Şimdi DAB
doğrultsal noktalarmış. Yani ne demek
istiyor? Şurası diyor doğru. Doğru
çizdik diyor. Burada bazı açıların
eşitliğinden bahsetmiş ama onları zaten
çizgi çizgi, nokta nokta belirtmiş.
Üstünden geçmiyorum. 36 mı var? Evet,
şekilde var. Buna göre AEC neresi? AEC
zaten X olarak sormuş. Hadi kolları
sıvıyalım. Şimdi ne yapabiliriz?
Birincisi
burada hiç bilmediğim arkadaşlarımız
var. Dolayısıyla ben onlara m ve ya da X
Y demeyeyim ama şeyler var. X var zaten.
Dolayısıyla MN diyelim. Yolumuza bir
başlamış olalım. Buradan sonra ne
yapabilirsek yapacağız. Tamam mı? Ard
bütün tuşlara basacağız. Öncelikle bir
doğru üzerinde
ne var? Bak şurada ne var? 2 tane m tane
de n var. O zaman sen bana hemen şunu
söylemek zorundasın. 2m + 2n 180
derecedir. A o zaman birer taneleri ne
olacak? 90° olacak. Yapıştır hocam. O
zaman ben şurayı 90° buldum. Bak böyle
bir daha önce 90° işareti gördün mü? Yok
göremezsin. Biz işte o yüzden özeliz.
Şimdi bunu bulduysam soru bitti. Neden
bitti biliyor musun? Bak çalışacağım
üçgenin içini boyuyorum. Anında şu
üçgende çalışacağım ki biliyorsunuz
boyamayı severim. Yani ben kendi
dersimde boyama da yapmayacaksam ben
niye YouTube'dayım? Şimdi [kahkaha]
şöyle derin felsefik sorular. Burada
çalışacağız ve burada biz iki açıyı
biliyoruz. Kimi biliyorsun hocam? Bir
açı 36. Bir açı da daha taze geldi. 90.
3üncüye ne düşer? Bitti soru. O zaman
yapıştır. Şimdi 90'ım var 36'ım var. Çat
çat topladın 126 3üncüye ne düşer?
180'den 126'yı çat çut çıkarıyorsun ve
diyorsun ki x = 54°. Yapıştırdım,
geçtim. Neredeyiz? Katlama çatlama
olaylarına başlıyoruz. Şimdi öncelikle
yine sırasıyla müfredatınızdaki sırayla
gidiyorum. Açıortaydan bahsetmiş.
Katlamayla açıortay. Biz bunu zaten 8.
sınıfta da yaptık. Bak LGS canavarıydın
da o zamanlar. Kısa şoklarda
koşturuyordunuz, geziyordunuz. Neyse
elimde büyüdünüz oğlum. 7'den 8'den beri
takip edenler var. Hatta 5. sınıfta
izliyordum diyenler var. Ara ara
duygusallaşıyorum. Neyse cansınız.
Hepinizi seviyorum. Şimdi gençler önü
sarı arkası mavi renkte bir ABC üçgenim
var. Ne yapacağız? Derdimiz ne? Açıortay
oluşturacağız. Yani hiçbir açı yok, bir
şey yok. Ama ben istiyorum ki açının
mesela şu A açısının tam ortasını
bulayım istiyorum. Böyle bir dert
edindim kendime. Tamam. Bu derdi nasıl
çözeceğiz? Hiçbir şey yok elimizde.
Ne diyorduk? Kenar kenar üstüne
katlanıyorsa orada bir açıortay var
diyorduk. Dolayısıyla burada da AB
kenarını AC kenarının üzerine gelecek
biçimde katlarsak oluşan kat izi bizim
için neydi? AD doğru parçası Açısının
açıortayı oluyordu. Tamam. Köşe köşeye
gidiyorsa şey özür dilerim kenar kenarın
üstüne gidiyorsa köşe köşeye gidiyorsa
mesela ben şurada B'yi C'nin üstüne
katlarsam ne olur? E tam bu kenarın orta
noktasını bulurum. Yani kenar haritayı
bulurum değil mi? O da köşe köşeydi.
Birazdan yükseklikte de başka bir durum
oluşacak. Şimdi gel açı ortayı çözelim.
Katlamayla ilgili ama sana çok önemli
bir şey söyleyeceğim. Bak katlamalı
çatlama sorularda 8'de de bunu hep
anlatıyorduk. Özel bilgi. Katlanan
arkadaş gittiği yere de tüm
özelliklerini taşır. Tüm açılarını
götürür. Tüm kenar uzunluklarını
götürür. Aynıdır. Yani şimdi mesela
burada B açısı değil mi? Bak katlanmış
halde. E buradaki B açısı o zaman aynı
değil mi? Aynı açı. Bu buraya katlanınca
bir şey değişmeyecek sonuçta. Bu durumu
kullanacağız. O yüzden söylüyorum.
Katlanan arkadaş geldiği yeri
unutmayacak. Mevzu bu. Hadi 4. soru.
Şimdi önü sarı arkası pembiş bir ne
vermişiz? ABC üçgeni vermişiz. Kartonmuş
bu. Tamam. CD doğrusu boyunca ok yönünde
katlandığında A noktası şekil ikte
görüldüğü gibi BC kenarı üzerindeki A
üssü noktasıyla çakışıyormuş. Şimdi ben
ne yapıyormuşum? Önce bak ne yaptığını
bir anla. Yaptığım şey şu. A noktasını
yani şu kenar boyunca diğer kenarın
üstüne doğru katlıyormuşum. Yani kenarı
kenarın üstüne doğru katlıyorum. Ben ne
yapıyorum o zaman? Açıortay yapıyorum.
Kenar kenarın üstüne gidiyor. Çünkü
burada A noktası kafanı karıştırmasın.
Mevzu A noktası gidiyor da onun
bulunduğu kenar gitmiyor mu? O orada
kenar kalıyor. Sadece noktayı mı? Hayır.
Komple geliyorlar. Dolayısıyla kenar
kenar üstü ben burada açıortay
yapıyorum. Kimin açıortayı hocam? E
kimin üstüne katlıyoruz? C'nin. O zaman
burada C açısı için şurada X X
diyebilirim. Çünkü sizin açıortay
olduğunuzu anladım. Orada bir cümle
yazarsın. kenarı AC kenarı BC kenarı
üzerine katlandığı için burada bir
açıortay operasyonu çekiliyor. Tamam mı?
Sen tabii onu düzgün cümlelerde yazarsın
artık. Şimdi 62 derecem var. 6 derecem
var. E buna göre diyor x'in kaç derece
olduğunu bulursun. Şimdi sakin. Bana
neyi vermiş? 6 derece vermiş. Tamam.
Peki ben ne biliyorum? Onu beyaz renk
kullanacağım pembede. Şöyle daha net
gözüksün. Şu A'nın kaç derece olduğunu
biliyorum. Mesela bildiğimi bir yazayım.
Şurası 62°. E şuradaki C açısının bir
parçası gözüküyor. X burası da. Tamam.
Bir tane 6 derecem var. Tamam. Bundan
sonra artık yolumuz akıp gidecek.
Telefon çaldı. Ders bölündü. Kaç kere
diyeceğim size? Şu telefonları kapatın.
Neyse devam ediyorum. Şimdi ne yapacağız
gençler? Bak burada 62 dereceyi
kullandım. X'i de kullandım. Şu B açısı
ile ilgili hiç konuşmadık seninle ya.
Gel bir B açısı ile ilgili konuşalım.
Nasıl konuşacağız hocam? E şimdi ABC
üçgeni komple düşün. Bir 62'miz var. Onu
bir çıkalım işin içinden. 180'den bir
62'yi düşür. Ne kalacak benim diğer B ve
C? Şu hemen bak hemen şurada. Şuradaki B
açısıyla C açısında ne kalacak? Şuradan
8 7'den 6 1 118 mi? Tamam. 118° ikisinin
toplamı. B ve C'nin toplamı. E şimdi ben
C'yi de biliyorum. Tamamı 2x. O zaman
buraya 118 - 2x kalmayacak mı? Kalacak.
Şimdi bak bu böyle kaplandığında hani şu
kenar şuraya gelmiş oldu ya ve burası da
bana 6 derece verilmişti ya. E bir de 62
derecenin de şurası olduğunu
söylemiştim. 62'nin arkasını bulamaz
mısın? Bulursun. O zaman bana orayı bir
söyle. Hadi gel zoomla. Şu bana 62'nin
arkasını söyle. Yani şu açıyı söyle. Biz
o soldaki gütçük üçgenin içine bir
dalalım. Oraya da ne diyeceksin? Eee,
yine aynı aslında. 62 ile 118 toplamı
180 yapıyor ya. Dolayısıyla buraya da ne
kalacak? 118 kalacak. Şimdi gençler,
çalışacağımız üçgen belli oldu. Şurada 3
tane açı. Birincisi 6°, ikincisi 118.
Hemen topla. 118 ile 6'yı topladın. Eee,
2 14 şöyle 2 124. Bir de 3üncü açım var.
O da 118 - 2. Ben bu üçünü toplayınca
180 yapacak. Mevzu bu kadar. Hadi
yaptıralım. Nerede yaptıralım? Vallahi
şuraya alıyorum. Şuradan devam. Şimdi
bak 124 iki açının toplamı. Üstüne 118 -
2x geliyor ve bunların hepsinin toplamı
180 yapıyor. Hemen topluyorum. Nasıl
toplayacağım ya? Şimdi
şunu bir dakika ya. Ben 118'i bir
karşıya atayım mı? -118 olduğunda bunun
kaç çıkacağını biliyorum. Çünkü 62. 2
saattir onu yapıp duruyoruz. Şimdi de
62'yi buraya alayım. 2x'i sağ tarafa
alayım. 2x pozitif olsun. 124'ten 62'yi
düşelim. Burası 2 62'ymiş yine. Tamam. 2
tanesi 62 ise bir tanesi 31 diyor. X'i
buluyor ve kaçıp gidiyorum. Nereye?
Katlamayla yükseklik oluşturmaya. Şimdi
katlama ile açıortay neydi? Kenar kenara
gidecekti. Peki yükseklikteki mevzu ne?
Önü sarı arkası mavi renkte olan ABC
üçgeni biçimindeki kartonun B köşesini
BC kenarı üzerine gelecek şekilde
katladığımızda B köşesini BC kenarı
üstüne he
köşeyi yine aynı kenarın üstüne
katlıyoruz. Köşe kenarın üstüne
katlanıyor. O zaman ne yapıyormuşuz? Ah
doğru parçası bizim için yükseklik
oluşuyor. Oluşturuyormuş. Yani
yüksekliği buluyormuşuz. Bak köşe yine
aynı kenarın üstüne katlanıyor. Amacımız
ne? Yüksekliği bulmak. Peki hemen şöyle
sorusuna bakalım. Gel 5. sorudayız. Yine
önü mavi arkası sarı bir arkadaşımız var
ve şekilde de ABC üçgeni biçimdeki
karton AD doğrusu boyunca okun
katlandığında B noktası bak B noktası
nereye zıplıyormuş? Yine BC kenarı
üzerinde B üssüne gidiyormuş. O zaman
benim ne yapacağım belli. Burada 90
derece oluşturuluyor. Bu bir kere net.
But açısı 40 derece verilmiş. Burası
şöyle 40 derece. İngilizce desen var.
Telaffuz falan bunlar.
X'i soruyor. Bitti soru ya. Bu arada
soru bitti. Neden bitti? E sen şu açıyı
biliyorsun. 56. E bu açıyı biliyorsun.
90. 3üncüye ne düşer? Bitti. 90'la 56'yı
hemen toplaştırıyorum.
Çatır çutur şöyle 6 böyle 14 180'den de
146'yı çat çut düştüm. 7 4 3 4 eee dedim
ve x'i buldum. X'i soruyor değil mi?
Tamam. Tertemiz soru aktı gitti. O zaman
geldim dış açı ölçüleri toplamına. Şimdi
7. sınıfta bizi takip edenler şu an
rengini belli etsin. Hocam bir yazın
bakayım ya. Hocam ben sizle ilk şu
sınıfta tanıştım. Merak ediyorum. 5'te
tanıştım. 7'de tanıştım. 8de falan bir
bir yazın bakalım. Kemik tayfayı
görelim. Şimdi gençler 7. sınıfta
özellikle o çokgen sorularının hepsinin
çözümünde kullandığımız bilgiydi bu.
Burada sadece üçgen yazıyoruz ama
müfredat gereği aslında biz ne
biliyoruz? Tüm çokgenlerin
düzgün düzgün olmayan değil hepsi. Dış
açıları ölçüleri toplamı 360 dereceydi.
Ve biz hep çokgen soranında bunu
kullanmıştık. Hep bunu kullanıyorduk.
İşte burada da mevzu bu. dış açıların
ölçüleri toplamı 360 derecedir. Tabii
şimdi 9. sınıfsın yeni marif model bunu
ispatla diyecekler. Hemen gel
ispatlayalım. Çok basit bir ispatı var.
Şöyle biz şimdi dış açıları arıyoruz.
Şimdi sen ABC üçgenini çizeceksin. Tamam
mı? Benim derdim dışlar. İçi biliyorsun.
Bildiğimizi kabul ediyoruz. 180'i
biliyoruz. Şimdi dışlar. Şimdi bak
burada A açısının dışına ne dersin sen?
A üssüne e bu bir doğru. Dolayısıyla
180°. E ben bu A'yı istemiyorum. O zaman
180 - A dersin. Aynı mantıkla diğerleri
de 180 - B, 180 - C. Hepsini yazdın.
Şimdi bu üçünü toplayacağım. E burada
yapacağım şey taraf tarafa toplamak.
Eşitliğin bak eşitliklerin sol
taraflarını toplarsan A üssü, B üssü, C
üssü geldi. Sen bunun aslında ne
olduğunu biliyorsun. Bunlar nedir?
Bunlar dış açıların toplamı.
Diğer taraftakilerde
180 180 3 tanesi 540 yapar ve eksi
parantezinde de a + b + c yani iç
açıların toplamı demiştim ya hani bunu
biliyoruz 180. O zaman 540'tan 180'i
düşersek ne kalacak? 360 yani A üssü, B
üssü, Cssü dediğimiz dış açıların
toplamı 360 çıkmış oldu. Hadi yapıştır
sorusunu. Şimdi burada ne yapıyorum?
Neler vermiş bana? Verilenlere bir
kontrol edelim. 3x - 20 şekilde var. 4x
- 30 var. 2x + hepsi var. X'in kaç
derece olduğu sorulmuş. Kolları sıvadık.
Şimdi gençler, A açısının dışı verilmiş
mi? Evet. B açısının dışı verilmiş mi?
Evet. C açısının dışı verilmiş mi? Evet.
O zaman bu üçü de dış açıymış ABC
üçgeninin. O zaman bu üçünün toplamı 360
yapacak. Denklemimi kurarım. 3x - 20 +
4x - 30 yapıştır.
+ 2x + 50. Ben bunların hepsini 360'a
eşitliyorum. Şimdi lambur lumbur
çözelim. 3 4 7 2 de burada 9x
eşittir sağda bir 360'ım var. Kim
gidiyor? Şöyle. Aa -20 -30 -50 + 50.
Bunlar pazara gitti. Kimse kalmadı. Çok
temiz. O zaman x e= ne diyeceğim? 40
diyeceğim. İki tarafı da 9'a böldüm. 40
dedim. Geçtim.
Şimdi geldik esas mevzuya. İki iç açının
toplamı bir dış açıya eşittir gençler.
Tabii kendisine komşu olmayan dış açı
eşittir. Mesela şurası A, burası B. Bunu
ekstra hani bilmesen de olur da hani
bilince hızlanabiliyoruz. Mesela bir
önceki sorularda da söylemiştim. Yani
bunu biliyorsan tık diye çözersin
aslında ama bilmesen de çözebiliyorsun.
Göstereceğim ispatta da zaten kendini
belli edecek. Şu ikisinin toplamı bak
3üncü açının dışına eşit. Mevzu bu. Aynı
şekilde burada olabilir. E ya da burada
da olabilir. Fark etmez. Yani iki iç açı
kendisiyle komşu olmayan 3üncü açının
dışına eşittir. Şimdi nasıl ispat
yapıyoruz? ABC üçgenini çiziyorsun.
Tamam. ABC üçgenimi çizdim. 1. AB
kenarına paralel olup AB kenarına
paralel sen de bir C noktasından geçen
bir paralel daha çekiyorsun. Şimdi
paralellikten faydalanacağız. Neden?
Çünkü bu paralellikten bize Z'ler
gelecek. Mesela X Z nereden geliyor?
A'dan geliyor. A açısı bak şurada ne
var? Z var. Hop. Bunu buraya
taşıyabiliyorum. B açısı zaten yöndeş
açı. Bunu da yöndeşlikten dolayı
taşıdığımda N bitti. Dış açıya eşitmiş
işte. İki tane iç açı bir tane dış
açının kendisine eşit çıktı. Mevzu bu.
Tamam. İspatı nasıl yapıyormuşuz? Demek
ki paralel çek. Mevzu bitti. Üçgende
zaten genelde ispatlarımızı paralel
çizerek yapıyoruz. Aklımda olsun. Hani
hiçbir şey yapamadın. İspat sorusu
çıktı. Hiçbir şey yapamadın. Paralel
çizmeye çalışın. Tamam mı? Aklına oradan
gelir. Geldim 7. soruya. Şimdi ıdı bıdı
ıdı vıdı. X 2x soruda var zaten. 73 var.
X'in kaç derece olduğu soruluyor. E
tamam. Ne kullanacağım belli. Burada iki
tane iç açı vermiş bana. 3üncü iç açı
burası. E bunun dışı var. Tamam. O zaman
bunlar iki iç açı toplaşınca 3ünc açının
dışına eşit olacak. Topladığımda 3x + 10
73'e eşit. 10'u karşıya eksi gönderdim.
63 oldu. X'i de buradan 21 buldum.
Geçmiş olsun. Ben de geçtim o zaman. 8.
Şimdi dikkat dikkat sağlam bir soru.
Yarasa uçağı. Yarasa uçağı maketinin
üstten görünümü verilmiş. Diyor ki işte
açıları verdim. Bunlar zaten şekil
üstünde de yazıyor. 92 de yazıyor. X'i
sormuş. Şimdi dikkat gençler. Bak.
Böyle yani girintili çıkıntılı soruları
hiç sevmem. Oldum olası küçüklüğümden
beri ya bir düzgün çizin diye bir isyan
etmişimdir. Dolayısıyla sonra da şunu
öğrendim. Ulan onlar düzgün çizmiyorsa
ben çizebilirim. Sırf bunun için
matematik okudum. Oğlum ben. Kaç yıl
okudum ya? Dolayısıyla ben bunu
düzelteceğim. Al şuradan çizgimi
uzattım. Bak ne oldu? Burası dümdüz
oldu. Şimdi bu bana ne sağladı? Şunu
sağladı. Burada 92'nin bir kere arkasına
gidebileceğim. Tamam mı? Böylece de hani
sağ alttaki üçgenin de içine girmiş
olacağız. Buraya ne yazacağım? 88° hani
180° ya doğru açı dümdüz çizdim. Doğru
devam ettim o kenara. Dolayısıyla orası
88. Şimdi de şunu söyleyeceğim. Bak
burada
iki iç açının toplamı
üçüncünün dışına eşit olmayacak mı? Yani
şuraya eşit olacak. Ha o zaman ben 3üncü
üçgenimde
aslınd açımda yani alttaki sağ alttaki
üçgenin 3üncü açısını da x'li bir
şekilde yazmış olacağım. Müthiş. Harika
bir bilgi. Çünkü bunu yazabilirsem diğer
ikisini de biliyorum. Çat pat 180'e
eşitleyip devam ederim. O zaman hadi gel
yapalım. Şimdi ne diyeceğim? Buradaki iç
açıya aslında yukarıdaki üçgen için
3üncünün dış açısı ama alttaki üçgen
için iç açı oluyor. Dolayısıyla 8x 3x
daha 11x -2 -4 daha -6 Tamam. 3üncü açı
da belli oldu. Haydi toplanın bakalım.
Şimdi 11x 11x o 1x gibi oldu. Şöyle 11x
- 6
+ 88
+ x + 2 = 180. Tertemiz. Şimdi 11 tane
burada bir tane burada. 12 tane mi
yaptı? 12 tane x eşitliğin sağında 180
ev sahibi bekliyor. Şurada 88 2 daha 90
6 çıkar.
90'dan 6 çıkaramayan öğretmen olmaz
herhalde değil mi? 84 değil mi? 84'ü de
ne yapacağım? Karşıya eksi göndereceğim.
Yani -84 ne oldu o zaman? Sağ taraf 96
oldu. 12 tanesi 96ysa
bir tanesi 8'dir. X'i buldum. Hadi
geçmiş olsun. Tamam. Mevzu bu kadar
gençler. Dolayısıyla da ne yapıyorum? Bu
dersi burada bitiriyorum mu?
Bitirmiyorum. Dur lan. Oğlum ne kadar
kaçmaya meyillisiniz ya. İkizkenar üçgen
var. Dur son sorumuz varmış. Onu da
halledelim. Kolay diye mi acaba? Hemen
geçesim geldi. İkizkenar üçgeni
biliyorsun. Eee, taban açılarının
ölçüleri birbirine eşit. Kenar
uzunlukları da birbirine eşit. Mevzu bu.
İkizkenarın daha detayı yok yani. Gel
şimdi bunu. Oo, çok sağlam bir soru var
oğlum. Kolay olur mu lan? Dersimin en
sağlam sorusu demek ki. O yüzden kaçmaya
çalışmışım. Bu da size ödev olsun.
Hayır, bunu ben çözeceğim. Ödeviniz bir
sonraki sayfada. Şimdi gençler diyor ki
kırmızı renkli çizgilerin hepsi eşit
uzunlukta. O zaman ben şunları önce
böyle çizittir çizittir yapıyorum. Şimdi
bunun sayesinde ben bir sürü açı
bulacağım. Sonra da hangileri doğru
olduğuna bakarız. Burası 25 ise e sen
ikizkenar üçgensen senin buran da
25'tir. Tamam mı? Sen şimdi 225 bak ne
yaptı? Şuradaki üçgende iki tane iç
açıyı biliyorsun. 25 bura 25 bura. O
zaman ne yapıyorduk? 3üncünün dışına
eşit deyip oraya da 50'yi
çakabiliyorduk. Yani şurası da 50°
yazabilirim. O akıyor soru. E burası 50
ise açısı da 50 olacak. Çünkü burada da
ikizkenarlık var. Kenarlar eşit olduğu
için. Ondan sonracığıma buradan sonra
bak ne yapacağım biliyor musun?
Yapacağım şey şu. Şimdi gençler bak çok
detay değişik bir şey anlatacağım.
Eee ya da yok anlatmayacağım kafanı
karıştırmayacağım vazgeçtim. 50 50 daha
100 mü? Hadi bana 3üncü açıyı söyle. 80.
Burayı da 80 buldun. Hadi şurayı da sağ
tarafı da söyle artık. Ne oldu? 80
burası 25 burası 105. Ya o zaman buraya
da 75 mi kaldı? Haydi. Burası 75 ise
bunun ikizi şurası da 75'tir. E burası
75. 75 150cüye düştü 30. 75'in arkasına
da ne diyeceğim? 105.
Bütün açıları buldum. Şimdi ben yazayım
ama yine de A'yı 50 buldum. B'yi 30
buldum. C'yi de 105 buldum. Şimdi
bakalım. A - B yani 50 - 30. 50'den 30
çıkarsa gerçekten 20 de doğru. 2inciye
baktım. C - A. E C 105 A 50 çıkarırsam
55. Doğru. 3üncüye baktım. A ve C'nin
toplamı A ile C'yi toplarsam 155. Bu da
doğru. O zaman ne diyorum? Happy G
doğruymuş. Bak ne anlatacaktım orada
biliyor musun? Bak onu da bir hadi
içimizde kalmasın. Şurada bak bir üçgen
var ya. Şimdi ne demiştik? Kural ne
diyordu? İki iç açının toplamı üçüncünün
dışına eşit. Ama sen şimdi üçüncünün
dışını eee düşündüğünde
hep böyle bir uzantı arıyorsun ya.
Hep uzantı aramak zorunda değilsin. Bir
tane doğrunun içine o 3üncü açıyı
alırsan bu açının dışı için
sağdakinin ve soldakinin toplamı da
diyebilirsin. Bak gerçekten iki iç açıyı
topladım 100 mü? 3üncü açımın sağı ve
solunu topla o da 100. Yani aslında
üçüncünün dışında kalanlar toplamına
eşittir de diyebiliriz. Tamam. Ne olmuş
burada? Parçalanmış. 25 ve 75. Yani
mevzu yine 100'e götürüyor beni.
Dolayısıyla bu şekilde de söylemiş
oldum. Dersi de burada bitirdim,
noktaladım. 16. ders bitti. Ellerinden
öper hemen uygula, pekiştir ve yazılı
sorularımız var onları tokatlıyorsun.
Sonra geliyorsun 17. dersle devam
ediyoruz. Üçgende ne yapacağız? Açı ve
kenar ilişkileri diyeceğiz. 3üncü temayı
da bu şekilde. 3 mü 4 mü? Oğlum kaçıncı
tema olduğunu karıştırdım. O kadar çok
ders anlatıyoruz ki. Sizde kaçıncı
temadayız? 3. temadaymış. [kahkaha]
Tamam. Başta söyledim galiba ya. 3.
temayı da bitireceğiz. Sonra 4'e
geçeceğiz. Dolu dizgin devam ediyoruz.
Ama ısrarla söylüyorum. Bak şu kitap var
ya matematik temelimizi gerçekten
iyileştirecek. Yani işlemlerde
hızlanmanız açısından. Bak neler var
sana şöyle göstereyim. Mesela şöyle
alıştırma sayfalarımız var. Tamam mı?
Netlersen. Oğlum çok kötü netledin ya.
Heh. Kamera da şaşırdı. Kitabı görünce o
bile heyecanlandı. Şöyle bak. Görüyorsun
değil mi? Yani burada senin sürekli
böyle çöz çöz çöz çöz çöz çöz. Ne
yapmanı istiyoruz? Aslında elinin
alışmasını, robotlaşmanı istiyoruz. Ya
sayıları tanımanı, işlemlerini
hızlandırmanı istiyoruz. Bir gözümüz
artık üniversiteye yavaş yavaş bakacak
ve listede biliyorsun burada 9, 10, 11,
12 daha önemli. Hani 67. sınıf gibi
değil. Çünkü yazılılardan aldığın notlar
da direkt üniversite girişinde laps diye
karşına çıkıyor. Puanına ekleniyor.
Direkt ekleniyor. Yani o yüzden hem eee
yazılılarda matematik temelimiz sağlam
olursa yazılılarda da haliyle ne olur?
Daha güçlü notlar alırız. Temelli önemli
gençler. Dolayısıyla matematiğim x
faktör. Partikül matematik ile matcore
0dan matematik. Bak core ne demek?
Çekirdek. Matematiğin çekirdeğine
inanıyoruz. İniyoruz. Tamam. O yüzden
matematikli aram limoni diyenleri
bekliyorum bu kampa. Yarı yıl tatilinde
mutlaka bir hepsini şöyle her gün bir
tane ya bir tane yani tabii bir ders
yok. Üç bölüm var haberin olsun. Yani
her bir günü biz üç videoda yaptık. Tık
tık tık tık ama sen önceden açarsın
çözersin. Çözemediğinde gelirsin
gerekirse videoyu izlersin. Eee böylece
matematiğin temelini halletmiş olursun.
Ondan sonra üstüne çıkmak çok daha basit
oluyor. Bilginiz olsun. Hani bazen
diyorsunuz ya hocam ben bu konuyu
anlamadım yapamıyorum. İşte yapamamanın
aslında bak yıllardır tecrübe ya alma bu
kitabı almak hani alasın diye de
anlatmıyorum. Genel bir şey söylüyorum
sana. Tecrübe şunu gösteriyor bize.
Öğrencinin matematik temeli yok ki. Yani
oradaki işlemlerin nasıl ilerlediğini
anlamıyor ki. Ben ona ekstradan şimdi
üçgenleri anlatmamın da bir faydası
olmuyor. O yüzden üçgenleri
anlamamasının derdi çünkü benim oradaki
yanlış üçgen anlatmam değil. Matematik
temeli zayıf. Matematikler arası limoni.
Bir önyargısı var. Dolayısıyla bunların
önce kırılması lazım. O yüzden mutlaka
bir sıfır kampı yarı yıl tatilinde bir
atın. Tamam mı? Gerekirse gel sadece
videoları izle mesela. Ha burada tabii
ki de ne dedik? Elimizin alışması. Daha
fazla alıştırma çözmemiz gerekiyor dedik
ya. O yüzden kitabı öneririm ben sana.
Hani al tak tak hepsini çöze çöze git.
Mesela eee bunu Ağustos ayında
başlamıştık kampına. 9'a başlamadan önce
alan arkadaşlardan çok güzel geri
dönüşler var ki tren yolda da zaten
yorumlarına da bakabilirsin. Eee o
temelini sağlamlaştıracak,
güçlendirecek. O yüzden çok önemsiyorum.
Çok da o yüzden üstünde durdum. Hadi
bitirdim. Bir sonraki derse zaman
yeniden görüşünceye dek kendinize çok
iyi bakın ve matematikle kalın. Hoşça
kalın.
>> [müzik]
>> He.